hello there and welcome to playstation
grenade
the end of fortnite chapter 2 season 4
is almost here
and potentially the biggest event in
video game history is
fast approaching this week didn't see a
huge update
but there is still enough to get our
teeth into so sit your butt down from
anything between five and ten minutes
slap code adamaru in the store to
support me if you'd be so kind and let's
break down
week 13. hit the music
[Music]
so actually the biggest change this week
only happened on ps5 and xbox series x
with an overhaul to many aspects of the
game nothing mechanical
it's all visual i've made a dedicated
breakdown of all 20 differences in the
next gen update so i won't dwell too
much now but the campfire's burned
differently the smoke effects have been
improved and the storm has more pink
pink is good i'm sure you agree and the
greatest but most pointless update in
fortnite history happened
eliminated players now crumble into more
cubes
it's strangely satisfying there's a
whole bunch of other changes too but as
they aren't on all platforms just yet
i won't go over them in this video let's
crack on instead
over the past 14 days the past fortnight
of fortnite you could say
the beast has gotten closer the devourer
of worlds began to inch nearer with his
steely stare
never changing focus from us it's a
super slow process taking months but
when he got close enough to feel our
gravity
he swooped under the island and suddenly
completely out of sight he's gonna pop
up again we all know it but where will
that be
remember two seasons ago when midas
began building his device
the only way we could see it was in one
of the battle pass menus
i get the feeling this will be the same
as galactus is picked up on the war
table
there is already examples of galactus
being here but only a handful of people
are reporting this right now
but from these images galactus is
looking big by the way has the store
updated for you yet
i mean the layout mine is still the og
version whereas tons of people on my
discord have the new updated version
i wondered if it's the same with
galactus some people get the update
early
others like me have to wait forever
anyway i'm getting sidetracked like
usual the point is keep your eye on the
helicarrier lobby screen as we approach
the event
it may have clues that we need
[Music]
so how will our heroes fight the big man
in the sky
tony stark remains the answer and take a
look at his new
and improved battle bus it's now no
longer an air balloon
but a rocket powered jet-fueled atomic
driven defense mechanism
that should be a t-shirt that it's been
brought to my attention in the last
update that the glowing green i spoke of
on top of the bus
is likely the power of doctor doom the
theory is that the four bosses chosen to
arrive at the island to help
thor storm iron man wolverine and doctor
doom
have all given their abilities to assist
the nexus war effort
iron man's design skills with dr doom's
energy blasts
wolverine inspired resistant metals
although not
adamantium of course and storms
knowledge of conductivity and weather
effects in flight
hey i know this is far-fetched but it's
great to see people linking the plot and
narrative where possible
it makes the whole thing much more
interesting hang on are we forgetting
something
we are aren't we hud watch baby
the updates to hot watch this season
have been microscopic
i mean last time we met we talked about
a wall being plastered
this time well this time can you guess
have a go get it well this week the
wooden floor from the steps to the first
section upstairs
have been varnished i know your mind is
blown you're totally blown away by this
bombshell of information
so for almost a year now we've watched
this place grow and by the looks of it
it'll be ready by the end of season 10
rip
but one day penny will have a home or
maybe it's for the henchman
[Music]
have you found the bromance this week if
you haven't you can find the duo over by
the grotto on the east side of the map
they are no longer dancing or searching
or preparing to leave the island
this week they have found peace and
tranquility
i'm going to quickly retell their story
now skip forward to this time if you've
had enough of the bros backstory
back when season 4 kicked off we had
previously seen a war between midas and
his two factions
ghost and shadow each week the map
updated in some really
great ways to show shadow slowly winning
the war
before midas end game project of uh
breaking time and space
collapsed and both factions were reduced
to rubble somehow a single henchman from
each side
survived the tsunami and set up home at
retail row and the authority
respectively
then two months ago now they somehow
found each other
they both traveled to the same gas
station cafe and that's
when the magic happened even though if
we got too close they became aggressive
they had a truce moment something
clicked and they realized that there was
more to life than following midas and
his instructions
they became friends two weeks later the
duo now named bill and ted by the psg
community
stayed at the same hotel enjoying pool
parties band rehearsals
and murdering wolverines a fortnight
later the duo began looking for
something
first staying at the dam we were unsure
if they were searching for a new home
or maybe searching for midas and the
answers they deserve
by halloween the duo made it up to
sweaty sands and enjoyed dressing up
and the bromance blossomed even more
getting stronger every single week
this though was also the week that midas
returned to
fortnite but this was not the same midas
they remembered he was
undead we tried to bring them together
to see if there was some sort of bomb
there
but there isn't midas attempted to
recruit the henchmen
into his shadow realm force last update
the duo made it to craggy cliffs and
began preparing a camping trip
with their new backblings ggs to those
who guessed rightly that they were from
raptor
and elite agent the henchmen then chose
a boat and a tent
and i thought they were gone forever but
how wrong
i was they simply rejected the henchman
life and embraced
whatever the heck they are doing now
[Music]
let's see if they survive galactus
attack i i uh
i reckon ted is the kind of guy to make
the ultimate sacrifice
who's better below ted
so the battle to save our reality from
galactus begins very soon so we'll
likely see a countdown appear on the map
this week but this got me thinking about
an older easter egg
the one found at steamy stacks no not
not homeless simpsons donuts
i mean the hidden orange box in the
basement we linked this to the movie
tenet
but thanks to the pandemic i never saw
this film did you
and i'm starting to think it has more
importance than we realize
has anyone seen tennant is it by any
chance about time travel
because if it is i have a story theory
to blow your mind
but we'll look at that next week oh
there's a small change on the map we
looked at it last week
we noticed the gas station up at 20
sands had a downgrade
to a single floor well right now the old
two-story station has returned
i have no idea why this happened maybe
some coding was
accidentally deleted or something or
maybe this will be an area
obliterated by galactus that would be
cool
and finally as the event approaches i
started spending more time on the
helicarrier to look for clues
in a past myth chaser episode we looked
in the vault and found a big pile of
nothing and last month we also noticed
that an eye patch is on one of the
terminals
could this be a throwaway easter egg or
is nick fury
coming to coordinate our defenses
against the devourer of worlds
i'm certain there's more secrets to be
found on the helicarrier
if you spot any please give me a shout
on twitter
so there we have it what did i miss
please let me know and i'll be in the
comments looking at your theories
and ideas i am totally addicted to
reading your theories
on screen now are another bunch of code
adamarro legends
who used my code this week and sent me a
twitter dm with proof
or jumped on the discord and joined the
nade family thank you so much for
supporting me i truly appreciate it
i'm adam from playstation grenade and i
will see you next time oh we need a dad
joke
um what does iron man do
before he takes a bath he gets stuck
naked hey
see you next time
you